what's up guys Dave here from GameSpot
playing some total war war hammer joined
today with my strategic advisor which I
say hello hello everyone I'm rich from
credit assembly so you're gonna walk me
through this siege of good old Empire
shuttled off with these chaos kind of
looming over me so humming for you oh
I'm not looking forward to it only
worried so how should I kind of defend
against the siege where should I put all
my traps one thing for sure we've got to
make use of your towers you will duel
defensive towers here so to get those up
and running we need to make sure we've
got at least a unit in that victory box
their base I'm handgun as their dragon
yes Oh totally yet get those guys out
there we can even get our our wizard up
maybe if if this if this siege tower
comes this where the hand Gunners might
not actually be too good against melee
so you can protect them oh that's right
swordsman this is having that that right
balance where you can you can mix and
match mean they're pretty quick to get
up and down these walls now so you can
even position some guys just down here
the bottom of this scaffolding and
they'll still be pretty good to get out
their support for you we needed that
sounds good and there's no siege towers
over this side so let's a good amount of
range units over here we've got all
Balthazar as well so he's going to be
casting some spells I've got a hell
cannon aimed right at the middle of my
city something tells me they want to
take us down we could put our our
mortars down there in that courtyard
potential to drive our back some kind of
a counter artillery yep and we
definitely need these towers because
we've got more siege guys coming who
could have their piloted by chaos
warriors forsaken so maybe some great
swords what you think okay so there and
maybe a halberd over here yep
they think they're gonna approach that
way let me go a steam tank for you know
controlling one of our gateways yeah
let's put the steam tank at this gate
maybe if we keep our Demi Griff's over
here in like kind of middle ground and
got your choice yeah if you break
through that gate then let's get them
behind the mall is just in case who else
have we got knocking around I've got
some more hangers yeah you want to get
some guys up there on that Taylor to
your right just put into that wall and
get us there looks like there's chaos
warriors with Hal birds when I take that
wall years we've got great swords let's
get these great stores in front of the
gate you've got four great souls there
so you know you've got 10 we're up on
the wall got a couple days support maybe
somehow the DEA's because the chances
are they going to break through that
wall with a giant yes so here's an idea
let's make like if we make like a look
box box of death you know box of depth
of that Giants come into
move him to get one of the halberdiers
to a greatsword halberdiers hopefully
this steam cannon should just as soon as
that gay yeah first open someone's
getting a cannon ball to the head chest
anywhere lands and then we can keep
those reserved anywhere the wall gets
weak okay we've got a got one more
mortar team I think and I gotta move
there now yeah good we have got abadeer
maybe it's worth having them on this
wall you there is three siege I would
potentially have them down behind the
wall because they looked about ta any
fire obviously okay they can always
something yeah that will totally awesome
a warrior priest he might be good at
holding the gate with these chaps yeah
he's gonna be casting some of his battle
prayers if we can get some of these
buffs or some artillery on there on the
enemy as soon as they come in perfect
who else do we have we've got a couple
more units swordsmen and our light
wizard and let's keep on light wizard
kind of anywhere that he can mmm I mean
if you want to make use of your missiles
and you want to get a game up on the
wall but otherwise if you want to use
your hexes or your augments to buffer
debuff that's put in between these two
years see if you can snipe some dudes
with us these are a banishment or his
burning gaze and is that it I don't one
more swordsman let's just have him
siege engine come in that way save him
here but behind the ball yep report sir
all right now just a little bit of luck
we should be okay want to start off with
using the golden hands though I'm big
fan of this spell most does it looks
awesome if we can slow this that
battering ram is slow the bearing ram as
well they're really go for the gate over
there you know better olo giant steam
tank already wants to her as far as that
I can't even Bernie haha that way that's
a shame that is a crying shame to wait
again for another go it's getting back
over the gate maybe Cass a nice i did a
little bit better yeah all right he's
telling us coming quick I go on the wall
but see what our towers can do back
against them water maybe face
that way as martyrs these mortals even
is that all right I think that coming
for this wall this wall that's what to
do no they're coming here let's go that
way come feel like they're this sorcerer
they really want to take that point
let's just hope that our saw Sorokin i
met our men can place the source or even
there you go there now getting to range
of some of our hang Gunners so that
they're starting to do some sniping was
bang-up one wins of magic I need you
they've come in but very slow so you can
get some more winter magic on the go
okay yeah the Marauders are piling out
into my swordsman there's two units here
which I'm not that keen on let's I can
always come back down off the wall let's
get these swordsman support them it's
mine forsaken as well so they can edel
help him get are these girls warriors
are coming down maybe let's get our or
warrior priest over there to the right
hand side it's not used to who's the
power of signal yeah I wanted to take
that gate
how's the walls doing boys you're okay
doing all right social I'm up I've given
us on the other bearing ram but a giant
is kicking the door in so I suppose that
was data contingency yeah he's got a
nice surprise there when he enters oh
yeah thats teen tank is gonna put some
hurt in colix sunny is way over there
let's debuff those guys ruin their armor
a little bit we can just support from
above keep out so you can get stuck in
you're all right yeah buddy you can take
care of yourself right swordsman sea
cows warriors Oh another chaos warriors
are capturing a gate Demi Griff's charge
yep please have them save the gate we
need you the the kit that the warrior is
coming slowly to get on that wall
pepper is mine I come on down Griff's
got in yet
yeah cuz at the moment your your whole
North or the big motors in country from
from getting in because they haven't got
engaged yeah well actually no ahaha just
did he said it a gay comes tumbling down
you know what let's get the steam tank
out of gate just smash through those
dragon ogres I stuck it out he's gonna
start ramming them and scorching him
with his steam that's fine with me that
works me completely and these hannigan
azhar actually got in their own the
walls I mean the week in some places and
some places we seem all right this
maurya priest needs to come down dilma
good job they're hanging on in there hi
guys i know i've cast out the wrong time
sorry though to finish off these girls
worries oh there you go does the last
few Kerr's warriors are there like a
short is to soar up down on the wall
with Albert yeah that his let's get this
count let's get this warrior against the
saucer evangelist see here to see you
last longest yeah because the warrior
priests you know he's kind of a proper
hybrid character you can do a bit of
both he can do some of his battle
prayers and he also get properly stuck
into melee combat as well here at me
seems to be pushing back these monstrous
creatures that are pushing their I'm
done a good job absolutely just like
that we've was it I don't even think
Colette got through the gate he didn't
get looking he came over this way it was
like okay guys no he literally got to
the gate I just turned around didn't
even get chance to use his lining hammer
he's just he's disgusted well of the
forces of chaos are just gonna have to
sac another city yeah and for their
troubles they're just getting shelled as
they run away 00 trying stuff up there
we go
IDK down I think that when that was all
right we're well if I was gonna lose
that one to be honest I think we did
okay told Dolph she'll never fall well
lets you know well not today not today
listen sue happens next week but thanks
everyone for watching thank you for
joining me and advising me in this
battle oh yeah and yeah for everything
else will hammer to a war make sure you
stay tuned to gamespot com